according to statistics one of the
happiest country on earth with a
thriving economy and a nature that
attracts crowds of tourists
the highest market share of electric
cars in the world is recorded here
last september sales records were
reached
almost half of the new cars ran on
battery
the war on air pollution caused by
traffic at these latitudes seem to be
very close to victory
in the capital there are more zero
emission cars than in any other parts of
the country
oslo city center
and there's where my boyfriend lives
where we will go later to the west under
the oprah
they're building a lot of new houses
over there
you're not downtown but you're still
pretty close
guro lives on a small hill not far from
the old city of oslo her boyfriend lives
on the other side of the fjord
to live her love story she had to come
up with something
we are approximately here and my
boyfriend lives
i would say off the map
i think it's about nine miles
to go over there with my gasoline car
and return i had to pay 78 norwegian
crones which is about 10 swiss francs
give or take
i realized that with an electric car i
don't have to pay the road holes i don't
have to spend on parking no money for
fuel so the math was simple to do for me
and that's why i decided to go for it
guru's choice fell on a second-hand
electric golf
which she paid half the list price
today she proudly shows us how she's
equipped for energy supply
this is how i recharge my car
there is a socket on the wall over there
and here you see the cable connected to
the car
in the future i will connect to that
device i had installed yesterday
this way i will have the opportunity to
recharge my batteries faster
what you see here is a slow recharge
it's not the best but you can do it this
way as well
it's very pleasant to drive
it's a softer ride and of course it's an
automatic car you don't have to change
the gears all the time
acceleration is also pretty good
if you want to overtake someone or enter
the highway it's better with this than
with a gasoline car
i don't drive to work every day because
i use my bike i use it to go out at
night to go shopping
it's handy to have an electric car
while with public transportation it
would take at least twice as much
to go to the supermarket a few miles
from home guru would spend 50 crons
about six francs
money that she can now save instead
a very interesting benefit because in
norway road halls are frequent and
they're not only found to enter the city
but also on country roads
like this freelance translator many
norwegians replace their heat engine
cars enticed by economic benefits
we'll verify it by going to a car dealer
just outside oslo where the owner tells
us that 90 of the cars he sells are now
electric
the top here is a kia soul
we sold more than 300 units this year
out of a total sale of around 600 and
customer loyalty is zero
if you can deliver the car you sell it
if you can't do it in a short time
they'll look for a competitor
but when it comes to new models then
they agree to wait
since the entire market is on the
internet they order their cars and join
a waiting list currently around 5 000
people have already booked the kia niro
which will be launched only in december
of this year
this couple too was asking about the
electric kia niro
by the time we were done with our
interview they had already booked it
without even the possibility of trying
or seeing it as a car was not yet on the
market
to get an idea on the advice of the
seller the two had to take a look at the
hybrid version of the same brand
yes the brand new one
why
because it has the autonomy we need it's
simple as that
i believe that he said the kia has 301
miles of autonomy according to the new
very rigorous parameters so that's
sufficient
before there were models within autonomy
of 124 miles and that's not enough to
reach
selling an electric car is not a
sailor's job because the customer is
easy everyone has already decided before
coming to the store to visit us
this amazed us
buying a car in switzerland is the
second major investment after a house
people think and think it over
they compare models
why do norwegians just go for it
there are zero taxes on electric cars
zero that's why it's so affordable
you can have a luxury car at a
reasonable price
that is the most expensive but it's not
electric
it's a diesel
and here you can see the price of the
car
it's about 800 000 norwegian crowns and
car taxes are more than three hundred
thousand origin crowns that's about
forty percent of the total cost and
taxes to the norwegian government
a sum that corresponds to a heavy tax of
over 37 000 francs not exactly chicken
feed
the role of the government is
fundamental in norway
together with the parliament of course
they can decide what vehicles we will
drive in the coming years
now they no longer want us to buy diesel
cars
they want us to buy electric cars
at this point we want to understand how
the norwegian system works
we're going to the electric car
association a non-profit organization
that brings together 60 000 consumers
[Music]
it's the carrot and stick policy
the polluting cars are punished with
high taxes and heavy charges and no
taxes and no charges for zero emission
cars
plus other advantages such as the
possibility of using bus lanes
[Music]
the most important incentives are the
financial ones
at the time of purchase no value added
tax and no import tax makes the price of
electric cars competitive
also not having road tolls is an
important incentive at a local level
showed us a concrete example
in the high-end segment the import price
of an electric car in norway is almost
twice as much of the same car with a
heat engine but in the end the electric
car costs less
because it's not taxed
the example of tesla is not made at
random
last september almost a new car out of
five on the market was precisely the
electric car of the american company
yes of course i work at the stone's
throw from here
i come here to work every day and this
is one of the places to recharge and
it's free of charge here and you can
stay for three hours so i go to work and
then i come to take it back
this driver revealed another element of
the success met by electric cars
parking and public recharges are free
also to meet halfway those who live in
an apartment and don't have the
possibility of installing a recharging
device the energy used in norway is 99
hydroelectric so it's clean
we moved to eckeberg a residential
district of oslo in one town house out
of two there are electric cars
amelia and harvard even have one each
[Music]
we used
we lived in the center then we moved up
here
we had to go down to the city to bring
and pick up the children from
kindergarten
i tried with public transportation but
it was really difficult
i had a baby in the stroller one on my
back and one walking beside me it was
really hard getting on the tramway and
subway at rush hour
it's not easy to find parking in the
city center while for electric cars
there are free parking lots so we
decided to get an electric car
[Music]
amelia a trade union leader led the way
her husband
a manager in a large company followed
suit
i calculated
i calculated that driving an electric
car a tesla or my old fossil fuel car
would cost me the same amount per month
over the next 10 years therefore it was
a simple choice to sell the old gasoline
car and buy a new tesla
the problem is that it seems a little
too flashy for me i don't like driving
it
it's a big car
yes it's a big car it's long and wide
and has a particular style so you either
love it or hate it love it
harvard said the appearance on the
market of electric cars that cost as a
middle category car would have a higher
autonomy has meanwhile created
paradoxical effects
the demand for these models have been so
high that waiting times have now
exploded and reached two years
so who just received their car could
resell it at an even higher price than
enlisted price earning a third of the
value
once you get used to driving an electric
car going back to fossil fuel car is
like going back to the stone age
moreover when you find yourself in heavy
traffic and you actually see the
emission produced by the fossil fuel
cars in front of you it makes you feel
good knowing that you are not affecting
the environment
affected
since the late 1990s the various
coalitions that have succeeded in power
in the scandinavian country have all
supported the tax relief program in
favor of electric vehicles
the paradox is that this strategy was
possible also thanks to oil discovered
in the late 1960s in the north sea
with the exploitation of its black gold
deposits and thanks to wise investments
norway had formed the largest sovereign
wealth fund in the world
we are talking about over a thousand
billion dollars but where is also
heading to with this eco-incentive
[Music]
policy parliament has decided that by
2025 every new car must have zero
emissions and at this point the industry
needs to deliver
needs to deliver
but in this case
in this case isn't it a bit hypocritical
to keep selling oil
what i can say is that we will still
need oil for a few years
not only as a fuel for the transport
industry but also in other fields
we also try to ensure that extraction
platforms use renewable energy and we
try to minimize harmful emissions from
the platforms so norway is also an oil
producing country and it will be in the
coming years too
7 30 in the morning the city awakes
we get on a bus that runs between the
center and the oscars of oslo
in the traffic there are electric cars
hindering us in the bus lane
it's rush hour and with the big increase
in electric cars there is more traffic
it's much more crowdy now
so you had to change your schedules
you know the schedule is our schedule
now takes this into account we always
have a 30 40 minutes break before we go
back to the shift this is how our
managers solved it
but i don't know how passengers will do
it
[Music]
the rule states there should be at least
two people on each electric car if they
want to use the bus lane i hope this
will improve the situation a little bit
the increase in electric cars which
makes life more difficult for bus
drivers is helping reduce pollution
caused by traffic and invisible
pollution but that at certain times of
the year creates great problems
as you can see the city is surrounded by
many hills and when there's no wind and
it's very cold in the winter the lower
layers of air are warmer than the ones
on top
this creates a sort of cap above the
city and at that point the problem of
pollution becomes very serious
and then you have a very serious
pollution problems
last year
last year it was calculated that at
least 186 people died prematurely due to
local pollution
and this must be stopped
what we are trying to do is reducing co2
emissions by 95 over 10 years a pretty
ambitious goal
and if we want to reach it we need to
start with traffic since in oslo 61 of
global pollution is caused by traffic
we moved to the foot of the castle of
akrishus a medieval fortress set up to
defend the town which was never
conquered and that is now one of the
main tourist attractions
here we are in what is probably the
first parking lot in the world reserved
for electric vehicles
it's an old air raid shelter dating back
to the cold war
it used to protect us from the invasion
of swedish and danish barbarians and now
it helps protecting the environment
79 parking spaces and asylum coming and
going the police comes to check and give
tickets if the cars are not parked
correctly
can you imagine a free parking this big
well it's not even the only one
the challenge for recharges is to keep
up with the increase in electric
vehicles an increase that is over 100
every year
over the next three years we will triple
the number of charging stations there
will be many more both in car parks like
this and along the roads
we now have 1 300 free recharge points
and within 3 years we will have 3 100.
when there will be many more electric
cars circulating it will be possible one
day to ask to pay the recharge
it will still be much cheaper than
gasoline and we will get the invested
money
the back of the city of oslo is
convinced
in a not too distant future when
electric cars will be the majority they
will have to give up tax exemptions and
other privileges
for example several city administrations
including oslo have already decided that
new and more expensive roll tolls will
be introduced next year
and for the first time even electric
cars will have to pay albeit at reduced
rates
because that money is needed to maintain
and build new roads that are also used
by zero emission vehicles
but some people didn't take it well the
norwegians accustomed to high taxes and
inclined to respect the authorities took
to the streets to protest under the
motto of that's enough and no new
roadholes
with the improvement in technology and
the increase of their market share is
clear that electric cars will also have
to be taxed we think however that
starting now would be too early because
this could jeopardize the achievement of
the goal of registering by 2025 only
electric cars
yet already in oslo there are signs that
things won't be the same anymore
how come the parking for electric cars
has disappeared we didn't find it and we
were surprised where is it on google
maps is still there it's a political
decision to avoid too many cars in the
center of oslo
basically by the end of the year all
cars will have to disappear from the
center no exceptions the goal is to let
the citizens regain streets and squares
thanks to more public transportation and
more bike lanes only the electric vans
of traders and artisans will have access
to oslo
those who transport the disabled and the
horses of our policewoman
okay so the norwegian capital is the top
of the class but what about the rest of
the country
last stop we pay a visit to a family
from sun
a small town 31 miles south of oslo
here there's no chaos but the norway
you'd expect a fjord with a small port a
quiet life
[Music]
i am a doctor and even if we don't live
in oslo there are still some tolls
[Music]
in the beginning when i was commuting to
work the journey was quite long
with an electric car i could use the bus
lane
it meant half an hour more with my
family the less at work in
[Music]
traffic it's a fantastic feeling i must
admit but now many people own an
electric car so this thing was somewhat
limited especially in oslo but it's
still an advantage
when we decided when we realized that we
liked it so much we bought a second one
and we still had that so we had two
electric cars and still the big diesel
car
we thought that if we wanted to take
long family trips to see friends or to
our cabin in the winter we would have
needed it for our long journeys
i believe that in the last four years we
used it only once to go far away
eventually i think we will sell it
because we will take an electric car
with similar features about the same
autonomy and we will no longer need a
diesel
the example of norway shows that the
government with a targeted policy can
achieve important goals in the fight
against air pollution caused by traffic
oslo doesn't offer cash aid but
renounces to substantial tax withdrawals
on electric cars a success bound to end
if the benefits disappear
[Music]
the question is will we have bought an
electric car if they hadn't offered us
any advantage
the answer is no
not at
the second question is if they took all
our privilege tomorrow will we buy an
electric car now that we've driven it
and the answer is definitely yes
in order for people to start
appreciating what's new they must be
offered facilitations immediately
this is why in europe the phenomenon
isn't taking off
because there are no initial advantages
[Music]
in norway 2017 there were about 142 000
electric cars
that is 5.3 of the vehicle fleet
around 14 000 electric cars circulated
in switzerland around 2017
that is 0.3 percent of the vehicle fleet
there are no purchase incentives in
switzerland
[Music]